1.
Work on new projects
Dr. Ken Atchity, Author/Producer: it was disconcerting
to be validated for something that I believed
22 years ago and that I got a lot of other
people to believe 22 years ago.
Including Doubleday to the tune of 2 million
dollars and Disney to the tune of a million
and New Line to the tune of a million plus
and so on.
And then it didn’t happen and then suddenly
all these years later it happened and people
go “You must feel good to be corroborated?”
And I said “Yes I do.”
But the truth is it taught me the most important
lesson of all which is what I wrote into an
essay called The Waiting Room [from Ken’s
blog].
If I had been waiting for THE MEG to happen
or for any movie that I started 20 years ago
to happen, I’d probably be miserable (if
not suicidal).
But what you do in the waiting room is you
do something else, that’s how you manager
your time.
When you’re waiting for something, that
can be annoying and a burden and what you
have to do is other things.
So what I did was 50 other things and as a
result 30 movies have happened and hundreds
of books and a new publishing company and
lots of other things.
Yes it’s satisfying to see that the world
endorses what Steve Alten [Author of Meg:
A Novel of Deep Terror] and I believed in
22 years ago that this was a hugely popular
subject for a story.
And all the way along brave people especially
Belle Avery who brought it home and Lorenzo
di Bonaventura and other producers, they made
it happen too.
But I guess what it shows among other things
is don’t waste time hoping for something
to happen.
Do your work and then put it out in the world
and let the world take care of it, that’s
one thing.
And then part of it is to trust the work that
happened.
When you create this baby (THE MEG in this
case), if it’s a good baby it will survive
and it will show its muscles when the time
comes.
Maybe it’s been in hiding for all these
years but suddenly it comes out and everybody
knows it.
That’s great but what it tells the artist
I think is to focus on what’s at hand, what’s
in your workshop right now and do it well
and then don’t worry about things you can’t
control.
Focus on what you can control.
And I guess that’s my main feeling about
it is that we did a lot of work on THE MEG
at the beginning, we created its shape and
it finally came out and it did great and am
I surprised?
No, I’m pleased but not surprised because
I always believed it but I’m so glad I didn’t
hang my own personal psychology on it because
if I’d done that I’d have been locked
up by now.
Like myself, Steve went on to write eight
more books on different subjects too.
And built another career around his talent
and he’ll continue doing that.
He’s learned that lesson too that.
Was it disappointing that it didn’t come
out back then?
Well it felt like it at the time but in retrospect,
things are meant to be.
And I always say to writers that I manage
that every project has its own clock and the
only problem is you can’t see the clock.
So what you do is you put in the work the
best you can and then you screw the screws
on the cover and send it out into the world
and wish it well and turn to your next project
which hopefully you’ve done before you finish
this one project and that’s what the creator
does.
He keeps working on new projects.
So this world didn’t turn out perfectly.
God creates another world, maybe it is better?
2.
What No One Else Can Create?
Marc and Elaine Zicree, Screenwriters: And
so what he was doing was creating something
that no one else could create.
And he told me that he wrote every day for
10 years before he wrote a single line, a
single word that was uniquely his.
And then one day he sat down and he wrote
the words THE LAKE and he wrote a short story
based on the time when he was a little boy.
When he was eight years old he and a little
girl friend who was seven went swimming in
Lake Michigan and he came out and she never
did (she drowned).
And it was a story of her coming back as a
ghost and they told me that when he finished
the story, tears were streaming down his face
and he knew that he’d written something
that no one else could have written and it
came specifically from his experience and
his soul.
And it took another two years of writing everyday
before he could write something again that
was uniquely his.
And then he got to where he could do it again
and again and again and he became Ray Bradbury
because he was determined to do that.
I thought that was a great lesson to say ‘Okay,
what are you creating?
What can you create that isn’t something
of what others are doing, but that is unique
to you, that no one else could have created,
that you create something fresh in the world
that’s truthful and meaningful and then
you know you’ve done something worth doing.
So that’s been a great inspiration to me.
3.
Six Scripts
Corey Mandell, Screenwriter/Instructor: I
love my agent.
I think he’s the best agent in the world.
I’m repped at WME.
There is another agent at WME who I think
is the second best agent in the world.
Her name is Adriana Alberghetti.
And she said something once they I think is
so important for writers to hear.
She said that some writers get it and some
writers don’t get it.
And the writers who get it are all working
and the writers who don’t get it (most of
them) aren’t working.
And so as an agent she just wants to work
with writers who get it and this is what it
is.
A lot of writers think that to write a script
that changed your life to write a script that
gets you your first job or to get Ridley Scott
to hire you or to get a show whatever it is
you’re aspiring to, you have a career you
are trying to take to the next level, they
think it’s about having the right script
at the right time at the right place.
That’s not it and that’s a mistake.
That surrenders all control and power to the
Universe.
The reality is your job is to think in six
script cycles and you have to be writing the
right kinds of scripts, pitch perfect authentic
(we talked about that earlier) and assuming
you trained yourself to be able to do that.
You need to write six of those every two years
and the reason is you write six of these pitch
perfect authentic scripts one of them is going
to go out to the marketplace and just fizzle
and you will never know why and then two or
three of them will go out and they will start
to get some traction but then something will
happen and derail it.
And then there will be one or two that is
absolutely going to happen, you have the director
attached, you have the stars, there’s a
bidding war, there is no way it’s not going
to happen and something at the very last second
is going to derail it and one of the six will
actually go the distance and sell or it will
be that script that gets you the next three
or four years of getting staffed on shows.
There will be one of those 6 scripts that
will just catch lightning in a bottle, one
of those 6.
One of those 6 (you don’t know which one
it will be).
So if you are not working right now you ought
to be writing 3 or 4 of these scripts a year
because you are thinking in 6-script cycles.
So any one script goes out and it does do
what it needs to you do have to feel like
a victim.
It’s one of 6.
This is the key to working, you have two jobs
now.
Your day job and your weekend night job.
So if your day job is a feature assignment
writer for Ridley Scott or if your day job
is you just got staffed on JANE THE VIRGIN
(one of my students just got staffed.
She’s very excited).
You have to do everything.
You have to excel at that job.
But then on nights and weekends you have to
be writing pitch perfect authentic scripts.
And if you are not writing 3 or 4 a year,
then maybe you are writing 2 a year.
But you don’t stop writing these scripts.
Because one of these scripts is going to be
the thing that takes your career to the next
level.
And so the writers that don’t get it is
I’m working, I’m making money, I’ve
made it.
Plus I’m busy, I have a family, I’m writing
and there is no other time and I get that.
But the reality is the writers that get it
even though they are working they are still
always creating this new material and they
think about it in these 6-script cycles.
And so a lot of times agents drop the writers
who aren’t doing that.
And I get it because when I was a working
studio writer I wasn’t continuing to write
these scripts.
I was just doing my studio assignment work
and I was making good money, I was just too
busy and I didn’t want to do that.
My agent kept telling me to do this.
I didn’t.
And he said at some point your writing career
is going to end badly and I worked non-stop
for 11 years.
But I was a working writer but I never became
an A-list writer.
And the only way I could have become an A-list
writer is to keep writing script.
So there was another writer Erik Singer who
wrote a script and started to get all of these
studio assignments and making a lot of money
but he kept writing on his own time pitch-perfect
authentic scripts year-after-year-after-year.
And eventually one of them hit.
It was AMERICAN HUSTLE and so he is now suddenly
a huge writer.
I know the guys who wrote THE NICK (same thing),
they are staff writers and they are making
really good money.
They were writing stuff that they really believed
in, THE NICK was one of them and that script
just took them to a whole other level.
Alan Ball with AMERICAN BEAUTY and you can
just go on and on and on.
Often agents drop writers who might be really
great writers but they don’t get it.
They don’t keep creating this new absolute…so
it’s either they don’t keep creating material
or they are not creating the right kind of
material (it’s not good enough).
I have a lot of friends who are agents and
if you keep creating the right kind of content
even when you’re working and the content
is amazing and you play well with others,
it’s very unlikely that they are going to
drop you because that’s exactly the kind
of person they want to represent.
And in that case if they drop you, it could
be a conflict with their client base.
It could be a lot of things that have nothing
to do with you.
But if you are not doing all of those things
and an agent drops you have to look in the
mirror.
4.
Script Comparison
Carole Kirschner, Author/Consultant: I can
go back to Sean Ryan again (the one who was
so promising) and he got a job on a sitcom
as soon as he came to Los Angeles and then
he didn’t work for 6 years.
And what he did is he wrote and I think that
he wrote about 14 spec scripts.
And what happened is his scripts were all
good but nothing was getting him traction.
And he asked his manager, he said to his manager
send me an example of a script that is getting
somebody work and his manager sent over the
script that had the most buzz at the time
and Sean compared it page to page and said
he’d have three things on a page that were
really good.
But this one (the one that got the buzz) every
single beat was perfect.
And when he realized that he had not been
hitting the mark, he started to write and
hit the mark.
And in not too long of a time he got hired
on a show and that show led to another show
and he developed THE SHIELD.
So you just have to keep working.
5.
Nothing in Return
Danny Strong, Screenwriter/Producer/Actor:
I wouldn’t really call it early success.
I don’t even view it that way.
I view it as 6 years of no one wanting my
stuff.
It was some random person who was very kind
who was interested in a script.
But it wasn’t as if all of the sudden I
made it and it’s happening now.
So it really was a 6-7 year journey to selling
my project which was RECOUNT.
And why didn’t give up is because I had
something to say and I loved writing these
scripts and they were important to me and
I was working on stories and it just was artistically
extremely fulfilling where my acting career
was very frustrating and I worked.
I worked on some really terrific shows that
I’m really proud of but I wasn’t actually
getting to act very much.
So even when you’re working I would do episodes
of GILMORE GIRLS and I would do 4 episodes
a season and I would work on it a day or two
and that would be one of my only jobs for
6 months.
So it’s really about 7 days on set over
a 6-month period so what am I doing the rest
of the time?
I’m auditioning and trying to get new jobs
but that’s an hour a day maybe?
So really it was a creative outlet for me
of taking my creative energy and putting it
into something where I can actually just go
do it.
Whereas as an actor, you have to be picked
to go do it and then you rarely get picked.
So I just found it fulfilling and I also was
getting rejected left and right, script after
script, agents, managers, production companies,
everyone didn’t want my work for 6-7 years.
And I think I got to a point where I asked
myself “This is not going well.
What do you want from this?
What are you doing?”
And I asked myself Would I…and it’s one
of the key questions in the movie…would
I do this for the rest of my life if I got
nothing in return?
And I thought yes I would.
And then I just kept writing and it wasn’t
as if 6 months later…crack the champagne!
It was maybe three years later and I sold
RECOUNT as a pitch to HBO and just kind of
went on from there.
But there was a certain peace in knowing that
it wasn’t about selling something or success
(even though I really wanted it).
It was a kumbuya moment, but there was a peace
in knowing that whatever happens you just
keep writing.
So just keep writing and that’s what I did.
6.
Story or Character?
Peter Desberg, Author/Psychologist: When Jeffrey
[Davis] and I were starting we took a slightly
academic view one day and said what’s your
prediction about the approach they are going
to take?
Are they going to go more for story?
Or are they going to go more for character?
And we found out the answer is neither.
They went for conflict.
So if you were going to give us a premise
to develop, the very first step we would take
is Okay whatever the premise is where do we
get conflict out of it?
If there are two characters involved, how
can we make them but heads?
So if you were to give us a premise to develop,
the very first step we would take is okay
wherever the premise is, where do we get conflict
out of it?
If there are two characters involved how can
we make them but heads to do something because
everything would come out of that.
7.
The Name of the Game
Gary Goldstein, Producer: Writers (as one
example), I get query letters every day, blind
query letters.
“Dear So and So…”
It could be my name, it could be ‘creative
executive,’ it could be my name misspelled,
it could be anything.
“Dear So and So…”
Log line, short description, “Can I send
a script?
I’ll sign a release.”
Signed…John.
That’s what I get repeatedly all day long
in my inbox.
There is not one lick of research.
There is not one lick of anything personal,
like why is this the writer (the only writer)
who could have written this story?
Why was it so compelling that they chose this
out of all the stories in one’s imagination?
Why did they choose to send it to me?
Now I don’t want to receive the agony and
the ecstasy as a letter but something…a
drop, a kernel, something that stands out
and makes me think.
Makes me react.
Makes me wonder about this.
But they don’t.
I can promise you not even 1% do what I’m
describing.
So this is what writers learn from other writers
and the actors learning from other actors,
etc.
They learn the habitual tried-and-true, day-to-day
protocol which is usually very unsuccessful.
The ROI (the return-on-investment) in sending
blind query blind query letters has got to
be horribly frustrating?
If you’re a business, you’d be bankrupt.
So why do it?
Because this is what other people are doing.
You need to associate with more successful
people and you need to think about it differently.
If you were a fashion designer and you took
that approach, you focus on your craft, focus
on your craft, focus on your craft and you
sent out letters saying “Here’s my designs.
Aren’t I great!”
You’d never have a brand.
You have to think in terms of business.
You have to think in terms of ‘What more
can I do that others aren’t doing?’
As opposed to ‘What they are doing.
How do I stand out?’
Separating yourself out from the herd is definitely
the name of the game and anyone who has invested
that blood, sweat and tears, that sort of
soul equity of investing all of that time
writing 120 or 110 pages (whatever) of story
and rewriting it until it is just so.
But they want to share their wares with the
world.
Now they’re so proud of this.
They should invest a like amount of time figuring
out how to market and how to be a business
person and how to reach out to people and
how to do things differently than all of their
peers.
Like that’s a great measurement.
Am I doing what everyone else is doing or
am I being somehow, putting myself out into
the world and speaking of myself to the right
people in ways that matter?
8.
The Great Weakness
John Truby, Author/Screenwriter/Instructor:
A common notion (particularly about action
heroes), notion was always in the past that
when you have an action hero or especially
a super hero that you want a character who
begins as a good person (an upstanding moral
paragon) and remains that way throughout the
entire story.
But about 10 years ago Hollywood discovered
that that’s not the best way to tell the
super hero story.
That’s one of those examples of conventional
wisdom that’s not so.
What we care about is to see a character overcome
a deep weakness.
Now the audience thinks the story is all about
the hero achieving his goal because then we’ve
got success and that’s important and in
most stories the hero will accomplish his
goal by the end of the story.
That is not what the audience is most interested
in.
They can’t tell you this but we know from
lots of experience (hundreds of years of storytelling
that the real fact is not does the hero accomplish
the goal but does the hero overcome the great
weakness because that’s what makes us care
about that character.
We see them in pain.
We see them in trouble, right?
If they are already successful if they are
already good (and in some cases) a perfect
person, where do they go?
There is nothing for them to overcome.
So that’s why it’s so important to show
in the very opening pages of our script the
internal weakness of our character.
Now we may also want to give them qualities
that are likable qualities that the audience
can also hook onto.
Those are not nearly as important as establish
the weakness up front in the story.
9.
I’ll Take A Look At It
Jen Grisanti, Author/Consultant: I’ll never
forget when I was a studio executive.
There was a certain circumstance where this
happened where we had the network, the studio,
the show runner and the writer on the phone.
And the writer was so defensive to the network
notes.
And it was my job to go to the writer and
say you need to really hear the note, understand
the note, and then you pat best response that
isn’t going to put someone on the defense
and isolate someone is “I will take a look
at it.”
That helps to…first of all it’s positive
on the writer.
It’s saying that they are open (it’s not
saying that they agree with the note) but
it’s saying that they are open to take a
look at it and that’s all people want to
know.
What I think the biggest thing writers have
to think about when it comes to receiving
notes on their script is that even if they
don’t agree with the note at face value,
they have to understand there might be a note
under the note.
And the note that they need to make to themselves
is something isn’t working and I have to
figure out how to make it work because if
this person who know story is not getting
it, there is something going on in my process
that isn’t working and just be open to that.
I mean the gift with writing is and what I
always say to writers is that you have to
recognize first of all what is the blank page
is the only thing between them and a writing
career.
And how they fill that page is what makes
the difference.
So they can rewrite anything, that’s why
I say to writers I cannot tell you (it was
my job) how many show runners I had to talk
off the ledge after they heard notes and after
they heard notes.
After they heard notes from the studio or
the owner of the company, I had to be the
peacemaker and I had to really help them to
see at first okay I think the writers mind
may go “Oh my gosh.
This is a total page 1 rewrite.”
Very often it is not.
All it is is really thinking about the note,
understanding the note, and then if they are
open to it what I’ve seen (the best writer
for me) knows how to make the note go beyond
the note.
And that takes openness.
That takes advanced ability to really know
‘Alright I’m going to make that note there
therefore that’s going to effect a later
moment so I’m going to change that later
moment so that it links with what I just changed
and they know how to do that.
I think the biggest wall note is saying “You’re
wrong.
I don’t agree.”
I think that shows lack of openness and accessibility
and desire to make the story better.
Or writers will say I don’t get it and then
the executive or the story consultant will
go through it again.
And to the person giving the note there is
definitely a tremendous amount of responsibility.
I am definitely a believer that if you are
going to give a note.
And this is where I think to the person giving
the note there is also tremendous responsibility.
If you are going to give a note, give an example.
Show them what you mean.
So that they understand the note.
There are many consultants who will say “I
don’t think that’s my job.
I’m not the writer.
They are the writer.”
I am a believer.
I come from the studio executive perspective
where clarity is key in the outcome of the
story.
So if you going to give a note and give an
example of why it’s not working or what
you mean by it then you are going to have
a stronger chance of getting the outcome that
you want.
Elaine Zicree, Screenwriter: It’s a funny
thing but the thing that most affected me
was a very good script doctor that I had and
it was a script that I’d written.
It was one of my most favorite scripts I’d
ever written and it was one of my favorite
script ultimately.
But she said “This is brilliant.
I absolutely love it.
Now here’s the notes!”
But the fact that she said that I was brilliant
and that she loved it I thought “Well what
the heck?
What’s with a few notes?
I’m brilliant.”
So I think crazy flattery is sort of a way
of allowing somebody to feel special.
With crazy flattery all those notes seemed
like nothing.
You know one of the biggest pieces of advice
was “Hey, what you are doing has super value.
Now here is the work.”
And just going on that thing where I was allowed
to have super value at the top of the journey
really got me through as thought it was nothing
of those notes.
10.
How To Build Empathy
Karl Iglesias, Author/Screenwriter/Instructor:
For character (and I talk about this in my
Pixar seminar) because they are masters of
this.
They tell stories about toys, about monsters,
about bugs, about robots, a fish, a rat.
They make you care and connect with those
characters.
So there are a whole bunch of techniques and
you can see what they do and what the techniques
are.
For me it’s like there are three things
that you do is that you make us feel sorry
for that character, there are little moments
where you can create a moment in the story
where a character is unjustly abused or unjustly
mistreated or insulted or betrayed or neglected.
And so it can be any character and if that
moment is there you are going to feel sorry
for that character (at that moment).
It takes an instant.
So that’s one.
If you show that they are like us.
If you show their humanity for example.
If you show that they care about something
other than themselves, that’s another technique.
So there’s a moment in the movie LEON THE
PROFESSIONAL which is about the bad guy right
and it opens with him doing something bad
and he hurts someone.
You don’t know if he’s good or bad.
But he goes home and he takes care of a plant
and right away you say “Oh?
He cares about a plant.
So he’s okay.
He’s human.”
The other part is admiration.
So if you are dating somebody or if you are
trying to find somebody who is a good match
for you, that list of things that you like
in a person that’s an admirable trait.
So if someone is funny, who is responsible,
who is courageous, a whole list of things
you can add to a character to say “I admire
this.”
Usually they are like the best at what they
do.
The best ad executive or best agent or the
best cop…courageous…I have a whole bunch
of them.
The list is all in the book.
There are all these lists of what you can
do.
So if you do all of these things, if you show
clips of the moment you meet the character
(it’s usually like a three minute scene)
you can see all of these things being applied
in like 3 minutes.
The opening of WALLE after he’s done with
the garbage and he comes to his little house,
it’s a 3-minute scene and there’s about
20 of these techniques done.
This is how you connect with that character
in that one scene emotionally.
I also show a clip of an ad (it’s a commercial)
about a lamp.
It’s a one minute thing.
It’s a great ad for Ikea (award-winning
commercial) where they make you care about
the lamp.
And the joke about it is a guy comes out and
says “You probably had feeling for this
lamp because you’re crazy.
The lamp is only a lamp.
And the new one is better.”
The new one to replace it.
But it’s amazing once you know those techniques
and then you see them in action and you go
“Oh my gosh?”
I kind of always feel (I always give this
caveat with my students and to everybody who
hears me speak) that if you love stories (if
you love film) and you don’t want me to
destroy the illusion do not listen to me because
I feel like I’m one of the magicians who
gives you the trick of how it’s done and
then you see the trick and it’s not the
same anymore.
So I always feel bad about that because once
you know the techniques and you see a film
you’re are going to see them everywhere.
It’s going to kind of ruin it for you so
just fair warning right there that this is
how we do it and it creates that effect.
11.
A Participatory Experience
Michael Hauge, Author/Consultant: It’s not
an audience’s or a reader’s job to feel
something you have to elicit.
So that means you haven’t created sufficient
conflict or emotion in your story to elicit
or you haven’t created a premise (a concept
of a story) or you have it structured in such
a way that the conflict makes any sense or
can be emotionally involving because you’ve
given them nothing to route for or you haven’t
created empathy with the hero or whatever
it might be.
But it’s your job to elicit emotion and
emotion has to come naturally from the reader
and audience because of what you’ve done.
They have to be participating in the story
that you created.
That’s why for example empathy is so important
for you to create for your hero because a
story is a participatory experience for the
audience and the listener and the reader.
We become that character.
We want to experience the same emotion as
they do.
We don’t go to the movies because it’s
interesting to watch people do things.
It’s emotional for us to get to do them.
We become Jason Bourne.
We become Rose as she falls in love with Jack
and she’s on the Titanic.
We become the astronaut who is out in space
in GRAVITY.
We are a part of it.
We are participating in the action, in the
events of that story.
But we have no basis, no way to get into the
story if on a subconscious level become the
hero of that story and that’s what the empathy
and identification you create at the beginning
is going to do.
So if you’ve created a story with an empathetic
hero so we participate, giving them a clear
goal, and created enough logical and believable
obstacles to overcome then the emotion will
grow organically out of your audience because
they are in it and you’ve created the conflict
that will do that.
To me all roads lead to the outer motivation
and so if all you are doing is stringing together
obstacles to overcome and there is a very
similar mistake and that is people who think
comedy is one funny thing after another happening.
That’s not what a story is.
Story is a sequence of events experienced
by a hero who is pursuing a very specific
goal.
So if you are just throwing one obstacle after
another but we don’t care the hero or the
hero or it’s not clear why the hero is doing
this or what they are trying to achieve or
if those obstacles are illogical or if the
pace of the story lags, every thing is at
a very high level of emotion and creating
sort of peaks and valleys at an emotional
level so you have big moments and quiet moments
and moments of connection and moments of separation
and so on.
There are all those things that you do in
addition to throwing a bunch of things at…you
know car chases and fight scenes up on the
screen.
Which many people have tried and those movies
don’t succeed.
If it’s just car chases and fight scenes
it’s just a series of videos really.
But it’s not a story or a movie where people
are going to be involved in.
It has to alternate.
It’s not a resting point as if you stay
there forever but it’s like in a comedy
you don’t want joke…joke…joke…joke.
There’s got to be a serious moment or two
and look at any great comedy (look at any
decent comedy) and there’s going to be something
very funny and then there’s going to be
something touching or sad or romantic or there
is going to be a deeper connection between
the characters or there is going to be something
more exciting or there is going to be something
softer.
You want to vary the peaks and valleys, the
emotional level and pitch of the story as
we go steadily toward the finish line that
the hero is trying to reach.
So the obstacle is getting bigger, they need
to come closer together so the pace will accelerate
but if there’s only obstacles (one right
after the other) with no chance to catch your
breath, no chance to participate what might
be coming, no chance to explain what’s going
on and no chance to get closer and deeper
into the character, it’s going to be a very,
very shallow story with very limited emotional
involvement or appeal.
12.
Writer’s Mindset
Erik Oleson, Writer of MAN IN THE HIGH CASTLE
and ARROW:
My process evolves every time I do another
job I realize how much I didn’t know in
my prior job.
So I’m somebody who reads pretty much reads
every trick, every screenwriting book, every
script that I can get my hands on and I’m
constantly trying to evolve as a craftsman.
I’m also fortunate enough in this job to
surround myself with really talented people
and you learn a lot from other writers.
Like there are writers on MAN IN THE HIGH
CASTLE who have won Emmy’s…like Martin
Scorsese best friend is another one.
You want to really kind of learn from the
people around you and that just makes you
better.
So I can’t say that I have any set process.
Although right now as I’m developing something
I have to say that I’m a big fan of the
John Truby stuff.
I think he kind of hits the sweet spot for
me.
But I’ve taken them all, I’ve taken McKee,
I’m one of these guys who likes to read
new stuff about the craft and I figure if
I can learn something from any book, if I
get one thing out of it and it makes me a
better writer, I’m all for it.
Christine Conradt, Screenwriter: Just being
able to recognize your deficiencies and for
me when I read a great script and I go “Oh
my gosh this is a great script.”
I get really excited and go “What are they
doing that I’m not doing.
What can I learn from what this writer did?”
And so I think just constantly learning and
constantly reading and constantly researching
and having that in the back of your mind all
the time that you want to get better, you
will just gravitate towards things that make
you better.
Instead of finding that comfortable place
where you know you are good at writing this
so I can write this over and over, it’s
forcing yourself to stretch.
Because I think once you do that it’s a
great feeling that you’ve written something
good and you’ve done something you’ve
never done before, then you have something
you can feel really proud of.
You can learn from everyone and that’s the
thing, there are so many people who…I think
people just want to feel validated so badly
where they get to a place where they say “I’m
an expert and everyone should just be listening
to what I have to say about this.”
And it’s kind of crazy because yes you may
have put your 10,000 hours in, you may be
good at what you do, but you can learn something
from everything that you read, even learning
what not to do.
Even in really bad scripts you will find these
little moments where you’re like “Oh my
gosh, that was really well-conveyed.”
So just being open to those things and learning
from other people because people are constantly
adding to this body of work that exists in
the world and there is so much for you to
be able to read out there.
Just be open to what other people are doing.
But then again you have to love reading.
So many writers don’t love reading.
So read, read, read, read.
A lot of people want to start writing without
having read a script.
I just don’t understand it.
Erik Bork, Author/Screenwriter: Probably the
most important perspective has been to see
it as something I’m always learning and
I’m always growing and that that’s okay.
It’s not like I’m supposed to know it
all or be perfect at it and the things that
I write are just going to be great automatically
and others are going to love them.
To see it as it’s an ongoing quest of kind
of a self-development, self-education, I’m
learning with everything that I write, what
works better and not as good so it’s like
this journey of development that you are going
to sort of enjoy the journey as opposed to
I have to get to a certain place which it
is easy to feel that way because the world
works that way where I have to get the agent,
I have to get the sale, I have to get something
produced, I have to get the money to make
my movie.
There are these goals who might have in the
world that are a lot of times out of our control
and if you focus only on those goals like
what I can get, what I can achieve instead
of what can I express?
How can I just do what I’ve decided I want
to do which is be a writer and be learning
and growing and find some satisfaction in
that journey.
Because when you turn it into there have to
be these quantifiable in terms of money or
other’s reactions or whatever, then you
are putting all your power in this thing that
may or may not ever happen, that you can’t
for sure make happen no matter what you do.
So I think it seems counterproductive because
to be successful (be a professional) you want
to focus on the professional goals.
Well you do to some extent and you are open
to feedback and you are listening and educating
yourself.
I didn’t say just go in a hole and do what
you want to do and shut the outside world
out.
I’m saying engage with the world, with feedback,
with education, with trying to understand
and get better so it’s growth but making
it a positive growth for your self that is
about making me better and making my writing
better not making my results better.
Because when you focus on how do I give more.
How do I write something that is really going
to impact people?
How do I do that?
How do I figure out how to do that?
How do I get better at it?
You are then about giving to other people
and you will achieve success I believe more
when you succeed at giving more, you will
get more automatically as opposed to how do
I get the success?
How do I get the breaks?
How do I get the right person to read it?
How do I get people to like it?
It’s more how do I create something so wonderful
that people will just automatically like it
and I’m not even concerning myself with
that.
It’s about taking the power into your own
hands and being about how you can improve
your stuff and your self as a writer.
Having that approach I think is a stronger,
healthier approach that is going to lead to
more success more then if you do it the other
way.
13.
Not Good Enough
Eric Edson, CSUN Screenwriting Professor:
The number one reason why you are not making
it is the material is not yet good enough
because especially if you are not reading
the stuff that is out there you have no way
of knowing how good good has to be in order
to get noticed.
Coming in you have to be better than most
of the people who are now making a living
at it in order to get noticed.
But the contests offer…re-objectification…the
contests offer the concrete way to do that.
Work on it, work on it, until you’ve got
something you’re ready to test.
But now pick your contests carefully.
The first time you try it out pick smaller
contests (more fringy).
I mean do your research.
They should be decent, upstanding contests
and so forth.
Try it out…try it out.
Did you make the quarter finals or were you
swept away in the first pass.
Okay if that happens, you have learned something,
it’s not ready.
And you keep working on it.
And finally when you get to the mid-level
ranks and your script gets to the quarter
finals okay.
It did not make the top ten or the top 15.
Fine…you’ve learned something more.
Go back, take a vacation from it for a couple
of weeks, try not to think about it, then
reread it again, make more notes and go back
to work on it.
And it’s a way that a lot of neophyte screenwriters
(new screenwriters) don’t do or don’t
pursue which is you’ve got to be as a writer,
as a craftsperson you must be relentless in
your goal of creating quality material.
For instance (I’ll give you a for instance).
I’m working with a young lady right now
who was one of our grad students a few years
ago
(2-3 years ago).
She’s been my class assistant and stuff
like that so we knew each other pretty well.
She took her thesis screenplay from (I don’t
know) three years ago and I read it and told
her “You’ve got a great idea here…you
really do.
I believe in this idea.”
And we had conversations such as there is
no such thing as a bad screenplay, only an
unfinished one.
And I gave her some pointers and scribbled
things on the pages and she went back and
wrote it again (this is a feature film).
And I looked it and was “You know what?
This is better.”
And I went through and the sample editing
and the scribble, scribble kind of stuff.
And she looks at it and it’s a little bit
better.
She’s been through that process (well in
this case with me) it must be 6 times now.
I mean years have passed.
She had a draft of this when she went up for
her thesis 3 years ago right?
But I’ll tell you and I’m reading it once
again.
I’ll probably be looking at it again this
weekend, she is so close.
I kept telling her keep track of…don’t
lose your draft of your first draft, don’t
lose a copy of your first draft because a
day is coming when I would like to have that
in my hand and your final draft and put that
together in a binder and use this in class
and have people read the first draft and now
read the last draft.
It could be a wonderful, wonderful exploration
of teaching writing because this has become
viable.
She is now close to having an entirely shootable,
casting, really good social commentary screenplay.
Film Courage: What changed in those 6 drafts
over the 3 years or however many?
Professor Edson: Craft.
Craft.
Her mastery of…what most of them do is they
write what they mean and when it comes to
dialogue, please just blurt it out and it’s
called on-the-nose-dialogue.
That’s one of the things you teach…stop
it!
People do not talk like that, people talk
around what they mean not that there can’t
be confrontation and stuff like that under
certain emotional circumstances but it was
dialogue and less is more in terms of the
amount of dialogue.
It was description, it was about the use of
language and vocabulary and description using
irrelevant words - the, and, there…there’s
a whole list of the 9 most utterly useless
words.
I’ve got it back there in a sheet I pass
out sometimes.
All that is is filler.
All that does is slow the reader down.
It is developing a style in a way you describe
and offer exposition and description in scene,
scene heading, slug lines and then what we’re
looking at in stuff like that.
Drawing people in, where you put things, building
the plot in an ever better way (you can do
more here) that is what has been going on
for all those years.
14.
Value Of An Idea
Richard Walter, UCLA Screenwriting Chairman:
The most overrated part of the screenplay
equation is the idea.
Ideas are usually pretty useless and worthless.
Forgive me if I’m repeating myself I am
one of those people who believes that BREAKING
BAD is one of the greatest achievements in
the history of civilization.
I think it is really great drama.
So what is the idea that drives it?
A high school chemistry teacher gets a cancer
diagnosis so he decides to go into dealing
with an incorrigible former student of his
(a criminal) to support his family.
It’s the stupidest idea I’ve ever heard.
Many, many companies shot that down.
And yet it is this triumphant achievement.
62 hours of TV series, every frame of which
is engaging and captivating and involving.
So how did that happen?
And the answer is they told a good story.
It’s where the story, it’s really all
about story and at UCLA that’s what I believe.
Imagine if someone came up to you and said
“Hey I have an idea for a movie.
This guys stutters but he has to give a speech.
They hire a speech therapist.
They work on this speech and he gives this
speech at the end of the movie.”
If somebody told you that that’s going to
win the Oscar for best picture and best screenplay,
you’d tell them they are crazy.
And yet that is of course THE KING’S SPEECH.
And again I think it just demonstrates the
value of story and the valuelessness of ideas.
And I think that very young people are more
into ideas, they have great ideas.
I like to say if you have a great idea, a
really, really great idea for a screenplay,
that’s all you’ve got.
I mean what remains after that?
Everything.
The characters have to be invented, the dialogue
they speak has to be created.
It has to be punchy and peppy and provocative
and pungent (I’m just getting into P’s
now) and poetic and it has to be worth listening
to all for itself just because there is something
kind of charming about it.
But beyond that it can’t just be all for
itself.
It also has to advance the story in a palpable,
measurable, identifiable way.
Likewise expand the audiences appreciation
of the characters.
It takes time for me to give you an idea about
a movie it takes about a handful of seconds
to walk you through the story which takes
the length of the movie (a couple of hours).
So that’s where the value is.
15.
Story Structure Myth
Larry Wilson, Screenwriter: There is a huge
business (maybe an overly-huge business) in
teaching screenplay structure.
A 3-act structure, a 5-act structure.
And I know a fair share of screenwriting gurus
who are at each others throats of which structure
is the structure and I’m not saying there
is not a structure.
I would be in big trouble if I said there
wasn’t a structure and that a story doesn’t
have a beginning, a middle and an end.
But this reliance, this absolute need to follow
any structure map that’s out there and if
you don’t have a turning point on page 30
you haven’t done it right.
Or if you’re on step 5 of 22 steps, you’re
on the wrong step, you haven’t done it right
or any of this stuff it’s not true.
This structure business, it’s a business
and you need a diagram to teach structure
and you sell a diagram and it’s very hard
to say I have the best diagram unless you
have a diagram.
I mean you need a diagram to sell a diagram.
I told you earlier about my diagram that ends
on page 60 with someone dangling down.
It’s an emotional diagram.
It goes like this…Page 1 I’m going to
do this, this is going to be the best story
ever, Page 10 Oh my gosh I can really do this.
Everyone was wrong about me.
My parents can go F themselves!
I’m a writer.
On and on emotional and like Page 20 you go
this is really getting hard, the graph starts
going down and down and then you get to Page
60 and it’s like I’ll never finish this.
It’s my struggle.
It’s an emotional structure.
It’s an emotional diagram.
Film Courage: Wait…sorry to interrupt but
what happens after the hanging diagram?
Larry: Oh well you go into despair for awhile.
You put yourself to bed and then you wake
up and start again and it has a happy ending.
And at the ending it has a happy ending, big
bags of money, all the love and companionship
you ever wanted, power, you win right?
But it’s obviously tongue-in-cheek and to
make a point.
But the real point of it is
have characters who you believe in and you
believe that you can write them and they are
in some sense writing you, that they are coming
out of a place of truth for you.
Put them in the tightest, most impossible
situation you can imagine and get them out
of it.
And know that you have probably (if you are
writing a screenplay) in a 100 to 120 minutes.
And let the story flow and there will be natural
points within you doing that where you will
feel needs to go faster, needs to go slower,
that there needs to be more drama, there needs
to be a moment of rest, all these things that
structure teaches you and again I’m not
saying there isn’t a structure.
But those structure diagrams they can assist
you or they can be a cage.
They can be an absolute cage and they can
trap you and if you believe that you’re
a writer, you have a natural storytelling
gift that you need to honor, that you need
to respect or don’t be a writer.
Don’t think that you can tell a story if
you don’t have a natural storytelling gift
and you can’t tell when things are going
too slowly or things are going to fast and
just let if flow and then go back and see
if it’s structured right.
But this is another thing that will stop people
in their tracts over and over again if your
first act is too long.
Who cares?
You’ll figure that out if writing is rewriting.
And watch a lot of movies, read a lot of books,
I’m now because of constraints of time sometimes
I’m a podcast junkie.
I hear the most brilliant stories in podcasts,
stories that have natural, beginning, middle
and an end because they are true.
Just embrace all of that, embrace the movies
that you love, take them to your heart.
And if you’re a storyteller, the story will
emerge and it will emerge with a structure.
BONUS - Never forget this one.
Blayne Weaver, Actor, Screenwriter, Director,
Producer: The biggest lesson about writing
get up and do it.
It is a job.
I’m the kind of guy that I like a glass
of wine, I like some music going, that’s
very romantic and I’m sure Hemingway would
be very proud but that’s not really how
you get a script done or how you write that
many scripts and I am always writing so it’s
like you’ve got to get up and spend time
with your coffee.
You’ve got to look at it.
Sometimes it’s just sitting there not being
able to write anything that gets you 2 days
later to where you can answer the question
on paper.
Celeste Chaney, Author: Everybody says you
have to write and read everyday because it’s
true.
If you are writing everyday, the next day
you are going to write a little better than
you did the day before and in 4 years you
are going to be a much better writer than
you were 4 years ago.
I think a lot of writers are waiting for the
world to give you permission to pursue your
craft and you need to give yourself that permission.
You need to show up and say Okay I’m going
to do this and I’m probably not going to
be very good right now or maybe I am great
and I don’t know it yet.
You won’t know either way unless you put
yourself out there.
And sitting down everyday whether that’s
for an hour in the morning, an hour in the
evening, somewhere in-between the timing doesn’t
matter and it really doesn’t even matter
if you’re writing a 1,000 words or if you’re
writing 50.
The important thing is that you’re writing.